It's pretty annoying
to set your phone down
for a bit only to pick it up
later and see it at 30% battery
because apps have been
busy bees, syncing data
while you were out.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I'm
here to help you understand
what it means to be idle.
It's common for modern mobile
apps to be in a paused state
when they aren't active and they
have no pending notifications
or foreground services.
But what may be
new to your ears is
Doze mode, which lets the
entire device take a breather.
Doze mode works
on the assumption
that when the screen is
off and the device is
neither moving nor charging, the
user probably isn't using it.
So the device
decides to focus more
on preserving the battery than
syncing for new information.
To achieve this, Doze
mode delays things
like SyncAdapters,
JobScheduler, and AlarmManager
so that they don't burn through
battery when the user isn't
even on the device.
But to be clear, Doze does
not disable these services.
They just get deferred
to a later time.
These jobs and
background services
are paused and queued until
Android exits Doze mode,
for example, when the user
picks up the device again.
However, if Doze mode is active
for a prolonged period of time,
delayed jobs are batched up
and executed periodically.
But for some apps
timing is critical,
and so the Android
framework offers two ways
to get important work done
even when the device is Dozing.
Google Cloud Messaging
can bypass Doze behavior
with messages that are
marked as high priority.
In a social app, for
example, the notification
of a new follower
or comment probably
isn't vital, whereas a chat
message could be critical.
So if it's worth having the
user get up, cross the room,
and pick up the device, then you
can consider it high priority.
And other apps have
time critical operations
that they need to do, such
as prompting notification
at exactly 6:00 PM.
In cases like these, you want to
know that your AlarmManager has
your back.
Now setExact will not
trigger on the moment
if the device is Dozing, but
only when it exits Doze mode.
Instead, use AndAllowWhileIdle,
which will trigger even
through Doze mode.
But aside from
these two scenarios,
there isn't much that needs
to be done about Doze mode,
because your app is not
being ignored or skipped,
merely delayed until the
device itself is in use.
So the core of the work
that you want to do
is actually testing
your app to be certain
that your app's
recovery from Doze mode
is as graceful as expected.
So to help you with this, we
have created new adb commands
that enable developers to step
through the stages of Doze mode
programmatically.
So check the
documentation for details.
And that's really all
there is to Dozing.
Nothing too scary, and not too
much work for the developer.
So if you're
targeting Marshmallow,
you may need to add a
few AndAllowWhileIdles
and upgrade the priority
on certain messages.
But mainly, just check
your app for surprises,
and continue to
build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]